qui arrivent et s'est coupée je ne
marque un petit coup d'oeil déchets et
gestion depuis hier le château de
chenonceau remonte le temps enfin le
temps d'un tournage
regardez la grande galerie s'est même
transformée en loge couturière
maquilleuse technicien c'est ici qu'il
s'affaire ils n'ont pas de temps à
perdre
gagner du temps c'est d'ailleurs le
leitmotiv de l'équipe
c'est pour ça qu'il tourne ta
chenonceaux de rythme là sur ce film
c'est qu'en fait on a plusieurs décors
par jour ça que souvent on n'a même pas
une pièce sombre est une journée ici
reconnaît souvent de trois pièces dans
la journée de trois lieux du coup là
donc à construire
c'est absolument pas financièrement
possible économies de deux films pour le
service public
mais au fait de quoi parle ce téléfilm
bon rapidement c'est une petite histoire
dans la grande histoire
anne d'autriche reine de france et le
cardinal mazarin scène pourtant ils ne
peuvent passer mes raisons d'état oblige
le tout se passe au xviie siècle une
période cher au réalisateur
je trouvais que c'était intéressant et
est rare dans les fictions françaises
ce qui n'était pas très bien visiter et
pour le coup je trouve que
je trouve que c'est un voyage absolument
passionnant et les touristes
ils sont passionnés le château est resté
ouvert aux visiteurs qui prennent le
temps de regarder le tournage mais faut
les comprendre
sous la robe rouge se cache philippe
torreton une star du cinéma passionné
d'histoire faire d'histoire s'est
interrogé notre époque c'est pas
seulement rendre compte comme ça d'une
possibilité
véracité d'une époque non c'est
comprendre l'histoire c'est ce qu'ont
prendre nous-mêmes aujourd'hui et quand
on voit là la science politique de
mazara c'est intéressant de voir un peu
comment ça peut se traduire aujourd'hui
faut-il y voir un clin d'oeil à son
élection à la mairie du 9e à paris qui
sait une chose est sûre mazarin restera
à chenonceau jusqu'à vendredi
le tournage poursuivra ensuite en
bourgogne et en anjou